qu'un rapport avec des produits de santé
aux deux vaccins les seuls rapports que
j'ai c'est que j'ai créé une entreprise
de biotechnologie qui fait du diagnostic
sérologique qui pour l'instant est
déficitaire mais qui est qui a été
incubés dans mon laboratoire qui
s'appelle i nothing d'accord je vous
remercie donc je vous propose de
commandes c'est l'audition par un exposé
liminaire si vous le souhaitez ensuite
vous répondrai aux questions d'abord de
notre reporter monsieur alain milon et
ensuite des commissaires ici présents
alors si vous voulez j'aurais souhaité
comme quand nous nous en avions discuté
essayer de mettre les choses en
perspective pour comprendre une partie
de ce qui se déroule ou de ce qui s'est
déroulé dans la pandémie grippale h1n1
tel qu'on l'a vu la dernière et qui est
quelque chose qui de mon point de vue
s'articule très bien avec le rapport que
j'avais fait pour le ministre de la
santé pour le ministre de la recherche
il ya quelques années on m'a demandé
jean françois mattei que je connais très
bien et puis je connaissais très bien
bernard bigot qui était le directeur de
du ministère de la recherche mais
demander tous les deux de faire quelque
chose sur le bioterrorisme et je leur ai
dit que je ne voulais pas faire quelque
chose qui soit limitée au bioterrorisme
et sur les crises sanitaires d'origine
infectieuse ce qui avait été l'objet
d'une longue discussion
et parmi ces éléments mon rapport je
vais évoquer le problème des risques de
pandémie grippale et on se remet à 2002
au moment où j'ai commencé ce rapport et
gémit d'ailleurs aussi l'attention de la
terre la tension aussi sur l'absence
d'infrastructures dans le pays et
l'absence de quantification de la
mortalité au jour le jour et j'avais mis
même dans les recommandations jour et
ses recommandations 73 qu'il fallait
commencer à compter les morts dans ce
pays parce qu'on aura une catastrophe
sans s'en rendre compte et et j'ai remis
ce rapport au début de l'année 2003
s'est d'ailleurs avant la canicule
on s'est rendu compte au lieu la
canicule que personne n'était capable de
compter mort et qu'on se retourner vers
les croque-morts pour savoir combien est
vendu de cercueil pendant l'été et que
direction générale la santé est
absolument incapable de répondre au
ministre que j'avais contacté en me
demandant si je pouvais l'aider d'une
manière ou d'une autre au milieu du mois
d'août met de la canicule
il m'a dit que les chiffres des ges
étaient parfaitement rassurant parce
qu'il n'avait pas de chiffre
donc un certain nombre de déficit très
profond l'organisation existait était
notée anticipé est ce ce rapport est
disponible bien sûr sur internet sur le
site du ministère tout le monde peut
aller regarder les propositions des
banques
parmi les éléments que je crois très
important d'avoir à l'esprit pour les
maladies infectieuse et contagieuse une
des raisons qui mérite l'attention c'est
que dans les dangers auxquels nous
sommes confrontés
il y à des dangers qui sont mesurables
contrôlable parce qu'ils ne sont pas
contagieux c'est à dire que et c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles j'étais très
en retrait sur la maladie de la vache
folle où j'étais très en retrait sur la
grippe aviaire parce qu'il s'agit de
maladies ne sont pas transmissibles
c'est dire que même si beaucoup de gens
sont atteints si vous arrêtez la source
où vous arrêtez la maladie tandis que
dans les maladies contagieuses et sow
sont d'une autre nature
vous ne si vous vous pouvez arrêter la
source si vous voulez les maladies reste
contagieuse c'est à dire que vous ne
savez pas en quantifier l'ampleur et on
ne sait jamais on quantifier l'ampleur
donc c'est ça c'est réellement le
problème de la contagion qui est d'une
nature différente de toutes les autres
maladies qui est le risque de diffusion
à l'ensemble des gens qui en sont sus
qu'ils sont susceptibles donc c'est
vraiment un problème d'une nature qui
est une nature différente et ce problème
nature différente
j'ai essayé beaucoup de de développer la
connaissance et la culture de ce sujet
car elle est spécifiquement en france
pour des raisons structurelles
elle est devenue sous développés c'est à
dire que le pays alors que le pays a
entendu était le pays qui a réussi à
faire accepter la théorie du germe
hattori maladies infectieuses au 19e
siècle acte asteur la formidable épopée
de pasteur a fait que le pays a confié
l'affection et l'évolution soit les
maladies infectieuses à l'institut
pasteur qui était à l'époque à la fois
l'institut de recherche de transfert de
technologie de vaccination un hôpital un
service de consultation à ce diagnostic
internationale
et donc cette concentration des moyens
et cette certitude qu'il y avait un
interlocuteur qui était capable de gérer
d'une manière complète cette situation
extrêmement complexe parce que encore
une fois la gestion de la contagiosité
est fait appel à la fois encore
transfert technologies de la recherche
fondamentale l'observation des malades
et la mise en pratique
et tout ça a existé c'est un modèle
mondial et ce modèle entièrement disparu
sans que comme souvent je l'écrivais
dans mon rapport nerfs très très précise
c'est devenu un institut de recherche
fondamentale ya plus l'hôpital il ya peu
le diagnostic il ya plus la valorisation
il ya plus les vaccins et donc le pays a
mis un certain temps à se rendre compte
qu'ils n'avaient plus d'endroits dans
lequel il y avait à la fois des hommes
de terrain des hommes de connaissances
et des gens qui est des relations avec
l'industrie qui ne soient pas des
relations malhonnête mais des relations
transfert raisonnable avec une
connaissance mutuelle des uns et des
autres et malheureusement cette
structure
cette situation n'a pas trouvé d'issue
et bien vous voyez que le lit nvs si
nous étions restés avec glorieuse de
l'institut pasteur les mbs aurait été
collée à coller puisque le problème de
la plupart des problèmes deviennent vs
ont des problèmes qui vont affecter en
maladies infectieuses être contagieux et
voyez qu'ils sont complètement isolés
eux mêmes du soin sont complètement
isolés la recherche pour constituer une
troisième entité isolée
ce qui fait que il ya une véritable
réflexion pour savoir où est ce que sont
les hommes de l'art et les hommes de
l'art ne sont pas ensemble est donc
structurellement avant le problème
moi j'avais près donné comme conclusion
qu'il fallait créer des centres de
compétences qui mêle le soin le
diagnostic la recherche
le transfert et l'épidémiologie y
compris en proposant qui est des gens
delienne vs qu'ils soient délocalisés
sur les à l'intérieur des sites de
proximité pour qu' ils soient au courant
ils voient comment ce passe et les
choses et ensuite je vais dire comment
nous nous avons vu se passer les choses
et bien entendu elle n'était pas du tout
comme ça c'est prévu parce que on ne
peut pas prévoir ce que l'on ne vit pas
au quotidien
donc cette centralisation des centres
qui en plus de ça ne sont pas n'ont pas
de lien
géographique direct mais quelque chose
qui est extrêmement pénalisants alors en
quoi se traduit cette pénalisation c'est
que devant une émotion qui a été
suscitée par une formidable épidémie
chez les animaux que les oiseaux qui
était la grippe aviaire la grippe
aviaire a entraîné dans beaucoup de pays
pas seulement le nôtre en partant
beaucoup beaucoup du rôle de quelqu'un
qui a joué un rôle néfaste ans est dans
cet épisode qui éclaire été très
critiquée qui est assez rare ce qui est
le conseiller du ministre en hollande et
qui est un des grands spécialistes des
modèles expérimentaux de la grippe
il est vétérinaire donc les choses
s'expliquent souvent et donc plus y
voyant ces espèces des épidémies
dévastatrices les animaux et les
quelques cas humains très sévère a tiré
la sonnette d'alarmé
ce qui est bien ce rôle mais il n'a pas
eu de contre pouvoir dans son pays et
ici il est tombé sur une réactivité que
plus personne n'a pu arrêter un livre
dont je ne parlerai pas et qui a été
publiée qui est qui je peux vous dire
mon expérience moi j'ai publié un livre
que je crois être rationnel exactement
même moment qu'ils étaient publiés en
même temps qu'un livre concurrents qui
visitent la grippe aviaire à les tuer à
moitié de la population j'ai vendu sans
fort moins d'exemplaires que lui je le
disais des choses assez simple raison
que vous voulez et les b si vous voulez
je peux ce qui est mon seul objectif
c'est que je peux relire ce que j'ai
écrit disant avoir en étant à peu près
d'accord avec ce que j'écris à l'époque
même si la notion la connaissance ont
changé c'est mon orgueil à moi donc je
pense que là il a manqué en face le
tissu de la connaissance sur les
maladies infectieuses et les noeuds qui
permettrait d'organiser une réaction par
rapport à ça
donc dans ce pays il ya un déficit
structurel et ça se traduit par quoi
c'est que cette inquiétude qui ensuite
touche la presse qui ensuite touche les
politiques et le gouvernement s'est
traduit en panique et avec des plans et
en particulier un plan blanc pour la
grippe qui est complètement
déraisonnable c'est à dire que ont
commencé à envisager
et quelque chose qui allait avoir une
contagiosité qui n'a jamais été écrite
dans l'histoire de l'humanité pour un
virus qui n'était pas contagieux du tout
chez les humains avec une mortalité
observé qu'ils étaient seulement celle
des cas hospitalisés chez qui on faisait
un diagnostic donc tout ça ça a fini par
un concept de la grippe aviaire va
arriver la grippe aviaire va tuer 30%
40% des gens mais jamais une grippe n'a
tué ça c'est pas vrai et qui plus est je
vous expliquerai une des raisons pour
lesquelles la grippe ne peux plus tu es
comme la tuer à l'époque de noël et
espagnols et d'une part et d'autre part
avec une contagiosité extrêmes et les
gens finissaient par imaginer que
quelqu'un passerait donc dans les plans
il fallait fermer les stades faire les
fermes et métro parce que on voyait une
contagiosité délirante la contagiosité
des maladies respiratoires c'est
s'appelle le ix 0 chez nous ces deux
pour un c'est à dire c'est ça n'est
jamais que des tâches quid d'accord
c'est à dire que chaque malade en
moyenne contamine de personnes d'accord
donc c'est pas un malade ne contamine
pas 300 personnes en passant dans un
aéroport ou dans un temps va mais trop
c'est du cinéma c'est ça n'existe pas et
donc cette chose-là qui a fini par
prendre forme
avant ce gouvernement c'est à l'époque
de la grippe aviaire
ça finit par devenir une menace de
guerre nucléaire
géré par le sgdn avec le ministère de
l'intérieur et avec un plan blanc géré
par les préfets au lieu d'être
la faire face à de la compétence
médicale pour faire face un pour la
médicale qui va falloir gérer au
quotidien c'est et donc moi je peux vous
dire c'est assez extraordinaire parce
que on a essayé de gérer ça à marseille
ça a été complexe
en dépit que du fait qu'on a vu pendant
une bonne crédibilité locales les gens
nous font confiance donc travailler que
depuis longtemps ce un problème dont on
parle depuis longtemps une crédibilité
en dépit de ça si vous voulez
l'organisation telle qu'elle était
prévue est une organisation dans lequel
on passer de zéro lits spécialisés
700 lits or nous nous disions on aura
jamais besoin de plus de 40 lits
jardiner c'est pas possible à une
pandémie pareil et l'expérience a montré
nous on l'a calculé assez rapidement
puis le premier papier est sorti dans le
meilleur journal médical certains venus
en glandes journal of medecine en
australie à montrer voilà il nous faut
20 lits par million d'habitants pour
pour contrôler une grippe de cette
nature donc nous on arrive à lui et
chose on évalue quant où il fallait 40
lits spécialisés par million d'habitants
pour gérer une d'épidémie de cette
nature là ça n'a rien à voir avec le
fait qu'à marseille on est sanctuarisé
un hôpital de 600 lits pour faire face
un truc 600 lycées d'épidémique ça
n'existe pas l'épidémie paraît donc si
vous voulez tout ça est devenu de mon
point de vue c'est pour ça que j'essaie
d'attirer l'attention aussi longtemps
que j'ai pu sur le fait qu' on n'était
pas préparé à la grippe je sais pas à
quoi on était préparés ainsi a fait une
science fiction peut-être que ça
arrivera à l'avenir est imprévisible
genre prudent je sais pas ce que sera
l'avenir mais en tout cas c'est pas ça à
la grippe voilà la grippe c'est deux
fois plus de cas à chaque semaine et
ceux qui sont passés là une semaine
après ils sont gris même trois jours
après ils sont plus contagieux donc sous
les 7 cette vision là qui s'est
probablement construite après des
épisodes de crise sanitaire successives
avec une chaque fois une expression
déraisonnable une réactivité de la
société déraisonnable que c était pour
la peau pour le bioterrorisme afin de
l'analyser 700 poudre bioterrorisme
c'était que des fantaisies on savait que
c'était fantaisie dès le départ il ya un
type qui ont aidé la farine avec marc et
vivent aux bahamas et terrorisme donc si
vous voulez y avait une réactivité une
décision tout prendre et du coup un
transfert de ce risque infectieux ce
risque d'exposition à la sécurité du
territoire qui a amené une réactivité
qui était contre la guerre et pas contre
une maladie infectieuse et donc ça je
crois que c'est un des éléments
extrêmement importants avoirs et si
c'est le cas c'est parce que à la
différence d'autres domaines comme la
cancérologie ou la nutrition dans lequel
le tissu est assez fort
tissu développé pour les maladies
contagieuses est assez faible
il ya assez peu d'interlocuteurs et
assez peu de centres de compétences qui
aurait permis d'endiguer cette espèce de
deux d'hybris si vous voulez de 2 des
mesures qui a été prise face à un risque
qui était quand même celui de la grippe
aviaire qui était un gris certains
entièrement virtuelle va donc y avait
des cas sporadiques c'est ce qu'on
appelle une zoonose c'est une maladie
des animaux dont des cas son transfert
sont transmis aux hommes mais qui n'est
pas une maladie contagieuse
voilà donc c'est les éléments essentiels
dont je voulais vous parler et parmi les
choses qui me paraissaient parmi les
choses qui me paraissaient majeur aussi
à signaler c'est que en dépit de tout ce
que l'on va essayer de faire cette
direction cette gestion qui est passé
par un volet exclusivement administratif
plutôt que de se passer sur les hommes
de l'art et en disant écoutez aidez nous
à gérer ça emmener ce que vous avez vu
c'est à dire que la gestion de la
vaccination dans les stades c'est
déraisonnable
les gens ne comprennent plus ce qui se
passe c'est devenu on a un article est
en cours de publication là dessus c'est
devenu un enjeu la vaccination a cessé
d'être un enjeu médical pour devenir un
enjeu politique c'est à dire que on a
fait une analyse qui est assez amusante
sera la fois les journaux les médias
et là moi le mode d'information des
différents partenaires et leur
couverture vaccinale est bien
globalement la transmission est devenu
et le la gestion a été tellement
politique est tellement peu médical que
les prises de position ont été en grande
partie influencée par les opinions
politiques des gens les gens qui étaient
de droite et les gens de droite fait
l'analyse dans toute cette crise était
plutôt en faveur de la vaccination et
journaux de gauche les gens de gauche à
cette époque là était plutôt content
vaccination et si vous regardez les
sites médicaux les sites de médecins
étaient les journaux médicaux étaient à
95% pour la vaccination
les sites et les blogs d'infirmières
étaient à 95% contre la vaccination et
ça s'est traduit par ça c'est à dire que
nous dans la campagne avec sonia intra
hospitalière que long de la rue on a eu
60 ou 70% de vaccination chez les
médecins et on a 8 % chez les
infirmières
donc ça c'est extrêmement frappant donc
c'est devenu un enjeu qui n'a plus du
tout était un enjeu médical mais qui est
devenu un enjeu politique à une bagarre
politique c'est à dire que on a
dépossédé les médecins de la gestion de
la grippe est la conséquence en a été
question c'est s'il ya des vrais
problèmes gestion parmi les autres
éléments que je veux soumettre à votre
attention le la réflexion j'ai émis déjà
à l'époque dans mon dans mon dans mon
rapport sur la gestion dans les urgences
on a bien vu que cette gestion est
déraisonnable c'est à dire qu'on quand
on sait que les gens sont contagieux
quand les pompiers savent qu'ils ont une
maladie éventuellement contagieuse qu'il
s'agisse d'une fille avec une tout d'une
méningite ou truc est bien en dépit du
fait que les gens le sachent
on les remet dans le circuit au milieu
des urgences on les traite d'une manière
indifférenciée alors que l'on sait faire
du tri différencié pour l'éditeur près
cordiale ou pour rouler les accidents
vasculaires cérébraux et donc ce
risque-là qui est le risque de contagion
intra hospitalier atteint risque majeur
est que nous et c'est une des grandes
chances qu'on a eue avec cet épisode là
c'est que ça mobiliser beaucoup
d'énergie et qu'on a pu quantifier aussi
est en train de finir un travail là
dessus la transmission de la grippe dans
les urgences a été un drame épouvantable
c'est à dire que le nombre de
transmissions les urgences a été
considérable et encore c'est la partie
que nous avons mesuré et qui représente
probablement une partie faible c'est à
dire que les services d'urgence n'était
pas prêt les malades qui venait pour
d'autres raisons que ça à en attraper la
grippe alors qu'on a si vous voulez
organiser les choses qui étaient prêtes
pour quelque chose qui n'était pas la
guêpe pas le contexte dans lequel joue
les choses et ensuite un certain nombre
de réactions que l'on à vue y compris
dans la stratégie vaccinale étaient des
réactions dont je pense qu'elle était
liée au fait que depuis le début on est
prise on était prisonnier d'une dune un
mode de pensée qui était qu'on était
face à la guerre et pas face à la lutte
des médecins contre une épidémie on
restait face à la guerre et donc et face
à la guerre contre la grippe aviaire ce
qui explique en partie mon point de vue
l'idée c'est le virus allait pas bien
été beaucoup moins réacteurs jeunes
beaucoup moins immunisant que h1n1 qui
est un virus qu'on connaît bien qu'ils
avaient russe qui est qui est très
facile mais très bien les humains ont
c'est ça le plus longtemps ça fait
partie de mes poules vaccinaux depuis
des années donc on a pris des stratégies
pour ça en disant il faut un mètre des
aides que la chaîne qui est présent dans
le vaccin anti saisonniers n'a rien à
voir avec le h1n1
non mais c'est non c'est irresponsable
de cette pandémie
non mais c'est x c'est à dire que c'est
si vous voulez dans les virus il ya des
grands groupes
et puis dès que des grands groupes
viraux sous les achats ena vous savez
que c'est l'hémagglutinine alors à 12h
tu as donc ces deux antigènes majeur et
donc il y a deux dans ce qu'on appelle
des dents dans les variations il y à ce
qu'on appelle des glissements et les
cassures d'accord c'est à dire que il y
a des sceaux qui font h1 h2 h3 qui sont
les seuls qui ont été là mais contagieux
chez les hommes jamais eu d'autre que
lâche 1,3 peut-être que ça le sera
l'avenir appartient à personne n'en sait
rien mais ça plutôt ou n'importe quoi
d'autre
ensuite vous avez n'aura mine d'asse
pareil 1 2 3 donc à l'intérieur de ce
groupe là qui représente un groupe
antigénique qu'on reconnaît il y à des
variations qui sont des variations par
glissement des petites modifications et
qui entraîne les différents variant
alors bien entendu quand il y à un
nouveau variant antigénique vous n'êtes
pas protégé par la soupe d'avant mais ce
qui à chaque fois qu'on a eu besoin
d'immuniser contre h1n1
les vaccins ont toujours marché très
bien sûr fait qu'une dose et on a
toujours cultivé sa r1 tandis qu'amd été
colossal surfer brionnais donc ce qui
s'est posé comme question parlait pas
bien ce que je voudrais ce que je crois
vraiment c'est qu'un certain nombre des
leurs d'orientation et je joue je dis ça
je vis en parle ici parce que je pense
que ce serait intéressant
structurellement de ne pas répondre de
la prochaine crise d'une manière aussi
réactive en étant plus pondérées dans le
temps
dans l'efficacité c'est si vous voulez
que le on était tellement prisonniers du
schéma n'allait pas bière qui y compris
les stratégies vaccinales ont été basées
sur le schéma de la grippe aviaire
c'est à dire deux injections parce que
les démontrer que c'est petit et pas
très immunisant ont été obligés
d'utiliser un adjuvant parce que on
pouvait pas avoir des quantités aussi
considérable que ce que l'on avait avec
le vaccin mutuelle vaccins habituels
vous mettez ça dans un oeuf embryonnés
l'a9 embryonnés vous avez un nombre de
copies absolument considérable colossal
il se trouve que le vaccin de la grippe
aviaire au moins au départ est un truc
qui tue les gens que vous pouviez vous
étiez obligés de faire ça sur les
cultures cellulaires et la rentabilité
de ça c'est un millième donc si vous
faites pour la grippe aviaire vous avez
moins d'antigène et en plus il est moins
immunisant donc vous êtes obligés
d'avoir des substituts dont vous faites
des cultures cellulaires et vous vous
rajoutez un adjugeant en l'occurrence
l'adjudant expérience a montré c'est
quand même des bénéfices book de cette
règle a eu aucune conséquence en soit
partout ça fait mal ça fait mal quand on
injecte ça c'est enfin en pratique c'est
du cholestérol c'est pas une chose
extraordinaire monte à la tête avec ce
que c'était qu'un nageur mais si jamais
que du cholestérol c'est donc ça rend le
tissu la jungle l'injection vie le sait
rien d'autre qu on a joué mais l'idée
qu'il allait enfin leurs deux et que ce
serait insuffisant sur le plan
immunitaire est une idée qui est basée
sur ce que l'on pensait pas du tout de
h1n1
mais ce qu'on pensait du virus de la
grippe aviaire voyez donc depuis le
début on a été prisonnier le plan blanc
c'était la grippe aviaire le vaccin
c'est pas bien on était prisonnier de de
cheminement de grippe aviaire qui était
une grande cause nationale de quelque
chose qu'elle est destructeur après mois
celles qui sont proposées la lutte
contre les maliens contagieuse c'est le
vaccin donc je suis absolument convaincu
que on avait la chance c'est une chance
extraordinaire c'est la première fois
-hors l'humanité qu'on arrive pas parce
qu'il y avait
un délai un truc à créer les vaccins
suffisant pour pouvoir les mettre à
disposition
après quelques besoin de commander deux
doses par don par quand même non c'est
moins qui sont arrivés un peu tard que
si vous voulez il ya une chose qui est
peut-être qui était difficile à
expliquer mais je vais essayer de vous
expliquer ce une des raisons pour
lesquelles je défends le l'idée de
constituer des pôles de compétences
l'épaule de connaissances les choses qui
sont la puissance notre médecine et si
colossal si considérable que quand les
choses sont arrivées et qu'elles ont été
analysés notre capacité d'y répondre et
de lutter d'une manière efficace contre
et spectaculaire si vous voulez moi je
fais partie de cette génération
la réponse de la connaissance à une
question est hallucinante de rapidité de
vitesse vous preniez le sarce il a fallu
trois mois et identifier le virus faire
les modèles expérimentaux et commencer à
préparer du vaccin phase extraordinaire
ces titres on regarde donc notre
capacité de réponse est merveilleuse
mais au lieu d'utiliser notre capacité
de réponse est de développer notre
capacité de réponse qui est la chose la
plus importante de toutes
nous construisons des modèles qui sont
des modèles de prédiction et ça c'est
nostradamus c'est pas sérieux c'est
passé on ne peut pas prédire ce qui va
se passer là l'expérience l'a montré
après moi je suis je suis intéressé par
voir ce qu'ils faisaient les malins en
dix ans après dix ans elle pas pris
rien de ce qui s'est passé avec cet
épisode de grippe n'était prévisible
rien il ya des choses d'abord qu'on ne
savait pas qu'on s'est un peu mieux mais
que la mortalité la plus importante se
soit trouvé leur astre angevins 50 ans
s'est jamais arrivé dans l'histoire
d'une libre s'est jamais arrivé c'est
quand même c'est quand même
extraordinaire c'est au moment où le
froid est apparu que la grippe a disparu
face à ces chats m'est arrivé un truc
pareil c'est un truc absolument étonnant
donc c'est ce que j'explique ma depuis
le temps les maladies infectieuses pour
les autres c'est pas mon domaine de
compétence mais pour les maladies
infectieuses qui compte c'est pas le
principe de précaution c'est le principe
de vie
c'est à dire que on apprend au fur et à
mesure que les choses se déroulent
on apprend et il ya une chose qui nous a
appris extraordinairement quelques jean
galle que ce soit des états unis et du
mariage que ce soit venu mais c'est
extrêmement intelligent cia il ya un
groupe de journaux qui s'appelle plos
qe2 un groupe de journaux gratuits
d'accès gratuit à la paix de ce groupe
de plos qui a été financée par le
lassitude recherche états unis qui
s'appelle manège a créé spécifiquement
pour la grippe une une brosse à
placement extrêmement rapide
c'est à dire que dans les sept jours où
vous envoyez votre article s'était
immédiatement online que tout le monde
puisse l'utiliser une dédiée à la grippe
et ça ça a été essentielle nous on a
envoyé plusieurs papiers là dedans qui
ont été ensuite repris dans des journaux
avec un tri plus conséquent mais ça ça a
été essentielle c'est à dire que sans
arrêt de collecter d'analysé et de
transmettre l'information pour dire ce
qu'il y avait différents
dans cet épisode par rapport aux autres
une autre chose qui était très différent
qu'on n'avait jamais décrit que les
obèses étaient particulièrement
sensibles à ça c'est 7 c'est dans cette
maladie qu'on l'a vu et ça on a su ça
nous en juin 2009 on savait ça
etats-unis disent aimer tiens y'a une
surmortalité chez les obèses
donc si vous voulez là c'est pour ça que
pour en revenir à la vaccination
c'est quand on a au fur et à mesure que
nous savions qu'elles étaient les vrais
groupes à risque nous pouvons mais
encore une fois c'est pau faut lutter
contre la lourdeur de ses systèmes et
lui donner de la réactivité en situation
d'épidémie
nous savions qu'il fallait changer de
cible dans les produits et les
populations à protéger d'accord et donc
ça c'est une grande leçon c'est à dire
que en général dans les pandémies du
passé telles et telles populations les
sujets de plus de 65 ans sont à protéger
en priorité dans cette pandémie c'était
pas le cas c'était pas le problème alors
été on a su qu'après une partie
importante d'entre eux avaient déjà été
protégé donc ça c'est des leçons on
comprend au fur et à mesure et pour ça
il faut avoir des sens
de compétences dans quelles sont réunis
les capacités diagnostic d'observation
de d'épidémiologie de soins qui
analysent en permanence les données
qu'ils disent écoutez voilà ce qu'on est
en train de voir et qui analyse les
données internationales pour dire
écoutez voilà comment nous devons
évoluer pour être réactif face à cette
situation dont celle ci y compris si on
veut reprendre le modèle de la guerre
sous les vous pouvez pas décider plan de
la guerre avant de commencer la guerre
et puis dire elle change pas au jour le
jour et changent tous les jours donc
tous les jours quelque chose change et
il avait pardon il faut de
l'adaptabilité et il faut encore une
fois généré des sources de compétence
est source de compétences ses associés
de du diagnostic du soin de
l'observation du terrain et mettre tout
et et des équipes d'épidémiologique soit
capable d'analyser ça et de mettre tous
ensemble et donc je crois beaucoup aux
pôles de compétences jeu je crois je
continue à croire que c'est comme ça et
comme le plus grand pôle de compétences
que nous avions a disparu trentaine
d'années qui était l'institut pasteur de
paris avec l'hôpital pasteur avec tout
autour santé et bien il faut bien que le
pays trouvent des structures pour
remplacer ça parce que du coup ces
structures la loire bien merci madame de
cette intervention
je me tourne vers mes collègues mais je
n'envoie plus énormes et mauvaises mains
donc je crois que nous allons pouvoir
terminer cette audition merci monsieur
maintenant puisque toutes les questions
je vais vous poser
j'ai pu vous les posez merci monsieur et
je vous remercie infiniment 1-2 vous
êtes livré à cet exercice avec beaucoup
de patience et de pédagogie merci
merci vous remercie de prendre ce temps
ah oui mais vous savez c'est un choix
quoi très bien je vous remercie
infiniment de cette intervention il ya
très intéressante et stimulante et qui
va sans doute oui pour être à l'origine
de nombreuses questions de la part du
rapport et des collègues à qui je
refasse la parole et de nos collègues
présents bien entendu monsieur
pourrisseurs je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention mais peut-être vu
et et évidemment je suis moi aussi en
écoutant les uns les autres on a on a
évolué dans notre connaissance d'abord
de cette pomme de cette épidémie dans
votre connaissance du plan qui est mis
en place dans notre connaissance de
l'efficacité ce plan est dans la
nécessité peut-être d'une certaine
stabilité du plan dont les pôles de
compétences nous n'avions pas encore
pensé à ça mais nous avions quand même
pensé qu'il fallait dans les centres de
décisions qu'il n'y ait pas que des
experts qui conseillent les décideurs
mais qui est aussi des hommes de terrain
qu'ils puissent venir conseiller
également les décideurs et leur dire à
tel endroit
ce que vous dites n'est pas tout à fait
exact pour l'instant j'ai pas encore vu
ceci ou cela donc on se retrouve
sensiblement en phase avec ce que vous
venez de dire j'avais des questions
préparées mais vous avez pratiquement
répondu dans d'autres interventions que
j'ai pas à y revenir dessus
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que à
l'évidence et sans vouloir vous choqué
parce que je suis pas là pour ça et puis
je vous dis je suis bien d'accord avec
vous je connais bien jean françois
mattei et j'ai aussi beaucoup de mots
beaucoup d'amitié pour pau pour la
faculté de médecine de marseille
mais merde dans le vaucluse à côté mais
j'ai rencontré votre doyen et c'est pas
tellement longtemps
mais je constate aussi à la lecture de
documents et d'intérêts d'interview que
vous avez accordée au mois de septembre
dernier au monde que votre pensée à
évoluer également par rapport à
l'intensité de la grippe sur le terrain
clairement ce que vous disiez en concept
en dernier correspond sensiblement ce
que vous dites aujourd'hui mais vous
n'appliquez pas ça y est vous disiez
d'ailleurs la grippe a h1n1 ce ne sera
pas une grippette
vous disiez aussi si le froid arrive la
grippe h1n1 va se développer
or on a tous constaté un contraire donc
est-ce que la seule question que je vous
pose est est-ce que dans ce cadre là on
peut encore dire que les experts qui se
fiait sur leur expérience
ce sont véritablement tromper ou celle
ci c'est le virus qui était plus
intelligent que qu'il les a trompés au
bout du compte alors je je je dérape
chez si vous regardez alors les données
écrites et les données étaient visés
sont pas de même nature parce que donner
télévisée retransmettre l'ensemble des
données écrites pas nécessairement je
commence toujours quand on demande
écouter qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'il
va se passer je commence toujours par
dire je ne sais pas maintenant je vais
vous donner mon opinion d'accord demandé
mon opinion et mon opinion mais entendu
elle est comme celle de tout le monde
elle ne peut être basée que sur
l'analyse de ce qui s'est passé
antérieurement pour ce qui s'est passé
il ya deux éléments sous les dents je
cours pour lequel je suis très jeu pense
que j'étais seul tout premier dans ce
pays a attiré l'attention dessus et je
continue à penser que c'était vraiment
une bonne idée et que ça prend le mans
et des individus et les choses c'est que
les informations les plus importantes
qu'on avait je peux c'est pour ça que je
pense que la grippe ne tuera jamais
autant qu'avant c'est que on avait une
analyse qui est sorti en mars 2009 si
vous voulez
la grippe espagnole qui montrait que les
trois quarts des gens étaient morts
d'infection bactérienne thème encore au
fil du staphylocoque et que donc moi je
crois que j'étais premier que j'ai pas
de relation avec les gens qui vendent le
vaccin contre le pneumocoque j'étais le
premier à dire attends il faut faire la
vaccination propre record ce sera pour
important et contrairement à ce qu'on
enseigne en médecine il faut traitée par
antibiotiques la grippe relativement tôt
depuis six mois ils vous interrompez
dans la région vous avez été suivi par
ce qu'elle est les messins ont beaucoup
avec cette année contre le mans que je
te fais et ça je pense que ça fait si on
regarde et comprises trouve que par
chance j'avais dans mon laboratoire cet
été comme en sabbatique en congé
sabbatique l'anatomopathologie ce qui
fait qu'ils travaillent au
saint-aphrodise contrôle et donc il
faisait toutes les microbes si les
grippes aux états unis donc on voyait
déjà par rapport à l'espagnol il y avait
30 à 40% encore dans cet épisode de
grippe de morts qui étaient mortes
surinfections bactériennes et puis je
pas combien 60% qui était mort vraiment
de d'autres choses après pour vous dire
la malice de moi je suis gens qui font
les malins infectieuses dont il faudra
refaire le sud sont des écologistes tant
que ça les ronces et que tout ça c'est
des cds situation complexe dans lequel
il ya de multiples partenaires c'est une
des raisons pour laquelle je ne crois
pas aux modélisations et la projection
je pense la modélisation soit une
escroquerie
y'a pas de modélisation possible je vais
vous donner un élément qui est un aimant
incroyable que peut-être il fut pas si
vous avez entendu bruno lina âme et que
bruno lina a trouvé qu'on a trouvé aussi
ce qui est tout à fait extraordinaire
c'est une chose qu'on savait pas il y a
une balance
il ya eu une balance qui n a jamais été
décrite entre l'épidémie de rhinovirus
et l'épidémie de grippe et vous le
racontez ça c'est qu'ils se rendent
sextant du temps des îles a eu il là il
se trouve que je suis rédacteur en chef
du journal de l'europe et donc j'ai fait
un numéro spécial sur la grille pour la
demande et en particulier les
partenaires français voilà quelles sont
les choses plus importantes et bruno
lina d'odessa ce qui a amerri au papier
c'est à dire que y'a une balance dans
tous les prélèvements qu'il a eu il ya
une
une cinétique inverse d infection par
rhinovirus qui donne des rues
essentiellement mâle est très peu gras
et la veille que la grippe quand vous
parlez effectivement l'interview de
septembre on a du premier cas que que
l'on ait détecté dans le sud-est de la
france une envolée tout le sud est de la
france jusqu'en septembre toutes les
semaines on a doublé les cas toutes les
semaines toutes les semaines les
semaines et puis ça s'est stabilisé en
septembre pendant trois semaines et puis
c'est reparti en octobre et puis ça
s'est arrêté en novembre
et puis après ça commençait à diminuer
il n'y a pas eu de rebond et bien cette
période là où le sens qu'on comprenne
pourquoi l'épidémie grève n'a plus
augmenté en septembre elle était
contemporaine d'une épidémie des
rhinovirus
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils je ne dis pas
qu'il ya un lien de cause à effet en
tout cas il y a une relation
statistiquement significative entre le
fait qu'il y ait des rhinovirus qui ont
la même niche écologique si vous voulez
le fait qu'il n'y ait plus h1n1 ça
jamais été décrit la littérature ça
personne ne savait donc si vous voulez
le niveau de connaissances qu'on a
acquis la maintenant dans l'étude de
cette épidémie est considérable nous
apporter d'aidé des connaissances
considérables qui change complètement la
proche que l'on que l'on klondike en
elle là aussi sous les supporter les
gens qui sont extrêmement choqués parce
que c'est jamais arrivé la disparition
l'absence de grippe saisonnière c'était
un truc m'en fous c'est un truc
incroyable encore les parties qu'une
pandémie avec un déroulement
extraordinaire et on se trouve avec
moins de grip que ce qu'on en a jamais
eu
c'est un truc et sort bien donc si vous
voulez c'est pour ça qu'une fois je
crois que faut être prudent moi je tout
recommencer à zéro là il faut
différencier le savoir savoir total
authentique mais le savoir quand on
analyse des situations qui ont déjà
existé à se préparer à quelque chose que
l'on voit arriver sans en savoir le
devenir en essayant de de ça de voir
qu'est-ce qui est le plus capable de se
passer
pour revenir sur la notion de
de grippette je vais vous dire je
maintiens ce que j'ai à dire parce que
je me souviens plus combien ces mais là
les hôpitaux de marseille il ya eu 57 ou
60 morts d'accord je vais vous dire une
chose donc je serais très content que
vous transmettiez je suis comme la
plupart des gens persécutés par les
pompiers de mon hôpital ma faculté je
veux dire vous savez comme il ya de gens
qui sont morts par incendie dans les
hôpitaux depuis 15 ans à aucun accord si
vous savez ce que ça coûte
en termes fonctionnement de 2
d'investissement de nous empêcher de
travailler
on dit alors ça ça fait partie des
mythes pour lequel personne n'a le droit
de lutter contre les pompiers qui sont
considérés comme les sauveurs de
l'humanité qui arrêtent et empêche tout
le monde de travailler pour prévenir des
risques qui n'existent plus donc là vous
me dites l'écouté et finalement on sait
rien avant cinquante mans on s'en fiche
un peu finalement c'est pas beaucoup
c'est mort parce qu'on avait prévu les
autres il avait prévu 500 milles
je trouve c'est beaucoup en plus si vous
prenez les morts en question c'est les
morts qui sont des mangeurs et des
conditions sous et la mortalité
j'ai vu c'est aussi un des grands
bénéfices de cette de cette épidémie
il s'est passé pour la première fois des
stratégies de réanimation qui n'existait
pas à chanter inventé pour cette
occasion vous savez qu'ils font enfin
j'ai passé de ça mais ça c'est de
raconter ça mais fondée circulation
extracorporelle pour attendre quand on
marche plus du tout attendre jusqu'à
trois semaines sous circulation
extracorporelle c'est inouï s'est passé
un truc absolument inouïe en termes de
technologie donc tant mieux je trouve
qu'en plus de ça les patients étaient
jeunes ils pouvaient supporter trois
semaines de circulation extracorporelle
mais en pratique il est mort des gens
jeunes sur l'ensemble du pays vous savez
probablement plus ou mois et de gens
dont on a vraiment documenté que c'était
mort de grippe en plus une proportion de
l'ensemble ça fait les morts ça fait
beaucoup de morts
de mon point de vue c'est à dire que
c'est un problème récurrent d'une
mortalité qui est quelque chose qui est
importante comparée à des choses dont la
priorité aux la hiérarchie a été
considérée comme extraordinairement
important c'est regarder moi je sais pas
je sais qu'on est en train de re
préparer une loi pour encore augmenter
le niveau de sécurité des ascenseurs je
sais pas combien sont morts l ascenseur
depuis dix ans et a fallu en mourir
beaucoup on a dû tout changer de
l'ascenseur ça coûte un prix phénomère
les ascenseurs et il paraît qu'une
nouvelle loi pour encore réduire searle
avoir un ascenseur alors au bout d'un
moment ce moi ce qui m'intéresse à santé
publique c'est combien et m'excuse c'est
comme également apprécié nous dit
écoutez c'est pas important mais il ment
aux 2000 morts autre allemand jugé
encore pourquoi dans l'autre main les
dix mille morts à me proposer
moi je suis d'accord dix mille morts moi
c'est mon estimation sur la mortalité
par les bactériémies nosocomiales dans
les hôpitaux si vous dites écouter ses
plus importantes s'occuper de ça mystère
des 4000 et moi j 12000 d'accord parce
que là aussi
là aussi si vous voulez la mesure du
ministère c'est une mesure virtuel vous
le savez si vous êtes médecin c'est
comment on déclare les septicémies
nosocomiales ont dit voilà une bactérie
nosocomiale et on demande à trois
médecins s'ils sont d'accord dont celui
dont c'est le malade pour reconnaître
que c'est une infection nosocomiale est
de marquer sur le dossier l'exemple
vient d'avancer je peux vous dire
le résultat c'est que il ya moins d'un
tiers qui sont déclarés nous on a fait
ce que j'ai demandé je sais pas ce que
vous vous rappelez le rapport ce qu'ont
les gens appellent le syndrome baise
médecine qui existait en france qui
commence maintenant et qu'on pris la
mesure de la mortalité c'est à dire
d'avoir des facteurs de mesures qui
soient entièrement indépendant de
l'interprétation des médecins parce que
ces facteurs dès qu'il y a une
interprétation des médecins dès qu'il ya
interprétation les choses deviennent
complexes si on mesure que l'effet donc
nous on a mesuré sa les bactériémies
chez des gens qui étaient hospitalisés
sont 12 heures on a regardé comme il y
en avait qui étaient morts dans les cinq
jours qui suivaient nous nos chiffres
ses 12000 portant donc si vous voulez
aussi je suis surtout les choses ça fait
3 % des mortels 2,8 pour cent la
mortalité en france
d'accord c'est pas rien donc c'est là
c'est pareil on estime on estimé à tort
ou à raison vous avez comme on estime la
mortalité de la grippe en france
vous avez une idée de comment les styles
est pas inutile que voulons-nous le
répéte y écouter c'est une histoire
c'est une histoire très intéressante qui
nous connectera avec ce qui s'est passé
avec jean françois et avec la canicule
quand jean-françois
mattei à certains la canicule
j'étais avec lui comme vous le savez
c'est mon ami je lui ai dit écoute
regarde mais personne ne compter les
morts et donc regardons à compter les
morts
et donc il a fait faire par ministère
une étude qui vous expliquent à la fois
l'ambiance de la grippe et ce qui a été
découvert c'est à dire qu'en france
personne ne regardait les morts quand
vous voyez tout est virtuel que ce soit
pour les ascenseurs pour les pompiers
tout devient entièrement virtuelle et je
pense que s'il ya quelque chose à
introduire dans ce pays c'est le culte
du du nombre du dénombrement et donc
quand jean françois mattei a fait faire
ce travail il a fait faire ce travail
sur 50 ans
qu'est ce qui a été vu c'est que si vous
regardez donc le lac où elle voulait
pouvoir l'obtenir avec publié je crois
sur site du ministère vous avez 3 vous
avez pas eu une canicule mais vous avez
3 épisode dans lequel il ya eu plus de
plusieurs milliers de morts plus de 7000
morts en cinquante ans c'était 76 83 et
2003 donc une seule a fait l'objet d'une
enquête d'un travail mais en réalité
c'était la troisième que personne
n'avait noté parce que personne ne
comptait les morts à côté de ces trois
épisodes les deux autres épisodes
notables qui étaient 57 et 68 qui était
quoi les deux grands épisodes de grippe
d'accord et donc si vous regardez les
grands accidents contemporain de grandes
surmortalité où on compte en milliers de
morts et bien 5 7 8 mille morts et bien
c'est trois épisodes de canicules et
deux épisodes de gueule
donc vous voyez les choses qui sont
capables d'influencer d'une manière
significative la courbe annuel de
mortalité c'est et ça a été pour 50 ans
pour ce qu'a pu donner des pics ça a été
deux grands épisodes de grippe et et de
grippe donc de pandémie grippale et
trois épisodes de canicule ensuite quand
vous regardez dans l'année toutes les
années il y à une surmortalité hivernale
dont on ne sait pas la cause mais dont
on sait comme médecin que ses
contemporains de maladies plus commune
pendant la période hivernale et au
premier chef desquels la grippe et donc
nous mais comme tout le monde comme le
cdc comme personne
on ne mesure couple pic et voilà ici
vous avez cinq à dix mille morts c'est
la grippe cette agri c'est les
infections saisonnières la saison froide
des pays tempérés à l'intérieur de ça y
est la grippe et de la gastro-entérite
il ya des pneumonies il ya des
surinfections et donc personne
donc on est dans une situation envoyer
où personne n'a investi la connaissance
de ce pic épidémique qui tue entre cinq
et dix mille personnes tout le monde
sort son chiffre d embrasser la grippe -
c'est ceci cela m'embêtait on n'en sait
rien du tout ce qui est la plus grande
cause de mortalité variable dans ce pays
donc il ya un manque de connaissances de
base qui est considérable et ensuite
face à ce manque de connaissances de
base d'un coup parce qu'il ya une
pandémie tout le monde s'affole donc moi
je regrette beaucoup
les américains sont très réactifs mais
ils ont une très grande chance et volé
par rapport à nous et ils ont une très
grande avance sur le domaine des
maladies infectieuses c'est que chaque
crise comme ça nécessite une réponse
sociale qui est parfois démesurées
parfois trop cher mais c'est comme c'est
comme ça c'est pas plus mon sens dans ce
domaine là que dans d'autres la
différence c'est qu'il ya une proportion
qui est de 20 à 30% aux etats-unis à
chaque fois qu'ils aient consacré à de
l'infrastructure ce qui fait que chaque
crise augmente de l'infrastructure et
l'infrastructure du pays augmente et
donc si dans cette crise vous voulez 30%
avait été investi dans l'infrastructure
vous rendrez compte que l'on garde
réessaie 30% pour autre chose
voyez pour la prochaine crise et donc on
bâtir et au fur et à mesure ce qui est
le sens de ce que je disais quand
j'avais fait un rapport au ministre en
disant très bien répondre à l'inquiétude
sociale aux besoins politiques mais en
même temps construisons pour que petit à
petit se fasse des infrastructures des
centres de compétences qu'on renouvelle
sa que l'on essaie moi je suis très
admiratif de l'italie l'italie a
commencé pour le sida à dire écoutez
puisque c'est la réinvention de la
contagion il nous faut réinventer ce
qu'on a fermé les hôpitaux de maladies
infectieuses
il nous faut réinventer sa et donc ils
ont décidé c'est le gouvernement italien
qui a dit on va faire ça à un rom à un
bilan plus grande ville et puis la
capitale
on va faire des hôpitaux de maladies
infectieuses moderne moi je vous assure
je suis allé à milan je m'engage à y
aller
j'étais décomposer les pays sous
développés
à côté d'eux ils ont à l'hôpital à milan
dans lequel il y a quatre étages 2
de service de maladies infectieuses dans
lequel vous avez 25 lits en chambres en
dépression en p3 pour chacun des
capacités de travail de logis en p4 qui
datent de commencé il ya 20 ans donc
nous on a eu péniblement on a été les
premiers à voir cette chambre
d'isolement pour pouvoir traiter les
malades extrêmement contagieux à
marseille pau qui en avait zéro à paris
donc si vous l'ayez il ya un retard
structurel d'infrastructures de
constitution d'infrastructures qui fait
qu'effectivement et qui vient cette
absence de connaissance rend les gens
plus fragile plus poreux parce que on
n'a pas le tissu pour répondre à ça donc
je crois qu'il ya un vrai problème de
fond qui est il faut apprendre à
quantifier tout ça il faut apprendre
quantifier les risques de manière à y
faire face
et ensuite il faut créer de la dette
vivier un tissu solide qui permettent de
réagir à ça et ensuite est ce que ça ne
nous empêchera de commettre des erreurs
lors l'avenir sûrement pas comme un
repas sera notre vie à commettre des
erreurs comme on l'a toujours fait avant
mais après il sait c'est l'ampleur des
erreurs et notre capacité à bâtir une
réponse est oui mais c'est ça c'est la
base de la sagesse et la plus grande
manifestation de langogne
c'est ce que je crois mais j'en connais
mais je reconnais mes erreurs très
volontiers mais c'est pas du tout une
manifestation et je ne sais pas vous
monsieur juste heures important juste
peut-être encore une question pour
laisser mes collègues répondre parce que
malheureusement le temps passe et c'est
intéressant
la directrice de l'institut de veille
sanitaire
nous nous a quand même fait remarquer
que cette année il ya on attendait une
pandémie n est pas arrivé vraiment on
parlait d'une grippe saisonnière vous
avez dit qu'on n'a pas eu les rhumes des
rhinovirus y en a eu mais on n'a pas eu
une mais moins que les autres années les
guerres les épidémies de gastro entérite
il n'a pratiquement pas eu
on attendait le froid on a eu froid mais
la question qu'elle se poser ces
questions je vous pose c'est que on il
ya eu un un plan qui a été mis en place
de lutte contre la pandémie dans lequel
il y avait une vaccination massive était
ce utile ou est ce utile et comment
faut-il faire pour que ce soit utile et
efficace
il ya eu en a mis en place les masques
bon à jeter beaucoup on ne sait pas trop
ce qu'on va en faire
mais il ya surtout eu la mise en place
du lavage des mains et ça est-ce que
c'est pas en plus de il ya eu aussi dans
dans le plan et dans les dépenses faites
par l'état pour revenir sur ce que vous
disiez de la mise en place de services
et on a quand même acheter du matériel
de réanimation et cetera dans les
hôpitaux
donc il ya eu un investissement
intéressant qui reste après coup mais
est-ce que l'une des grandes leçons à
retirer s'était pas demander aux gens de
se laver les mains régulièrement et
continuer à le faire
c'est à mon sens est un des très grands
bénéfices c'est partout le message même
si si si à la fin il était un peu
lassant aéroports l'intrigué a été très
très répéter les gens sont les gens sont
mis de l'alcool sur les mains et ça
c'est une chose qui est
extraordinairement importante
oui je suis d'accord c'est un bénéfice
considérable moi je je je fais partie de
ceux ci voulaient qui pense que d'abord
que j'aime faire la recherche est donc
cette observation de cette épidémie nous
a appris énormément donc et c'est une
c'est une grande une grande avancée à la
connaissance pour nous et puis pour pour
beaucoup d'autres et ça 7 7 7
réalisations si vous voulez de la delà
de l'importance du lavage des mains du
passage des mâles alcool est une chose
qui est tout à fait tout à fait
extraordinaire et donc je crois que ça
sera extrêmement utile à l'avenir le
pays tout à fait je pense que c'est une
sucette une star bénéfices considérables
pour la société je pense que c'était
et ce d'une nouvelle pandémie si elle
arrive un jour comment organiser la
vaccination
écoutez il ya je crois qu'il ya
plusieurs choses
il ya on est en train de réfléchir là
dessus on est en train de faire un
article pour essayer de voir comment
face à une nouvelle situation on se
retrouvait pas dans une situation
comparable
la première c'est celle ci c'est que moi
je crois j'ai bien suivi l'histoire de
la vaccination d'hépatite b je crois que
c'est ce qui a suivi le déroulement qui
nous mettraient si on avait une
obligation vaccinale
aux états unis il ya déjà dédé bd d état
dans lequel la vaccination pour la
grippe était obligatoire donc les gens
qui le prenait pas été renvoyé on peut
pas faire ça parce que on sait que la
législation française d'ici un doute et
on n'arrive jamais enlever un doute
par définition il doit bénéficier à
celui qui a eu l'obligation est donc on
seront récré dans l'exacte e mans les
mêmes conditions de quelqu'un dirait
mais il ya un doute pour le lien de
causalité entre la vaccination et
n'importe quel n'importe quel événement
qui serait produit la semaine qui suit
l'état soient obligées d'indemniser
comme c'est le cas pour l'armée donc on
peut pas revenir sur l'obligation
en revanche ce que je crois très
important mais parce que c'est mon point
de vue c'est que si on accepte la
nécessité d'avoir des services
spécialisés qui je crois va s'imposer
dans les études qu'on va faire sur la
contagiosité intra hospitalière que les
gens qui ont une grippe doivent pas être
envoyées aux halles avec les aléas d
urgence une fois en neurologie une fois
ce qui se fait actuellement
donc je crois qu'il faut
structurellement avoir un pré
acheminement d urgence infectieuses dans
un site dans lequel ne se mélange pas
avec les autres
la deuxième chose la deuxième leçon de
l'épidémie c'est que on sait qu'il faut
pour un million d'habitants entre 20 et
40 lits pour une épidémie de cet ordre
et y compris l'épidémie saisonnière
parce que nous on avait déjà rapporté
des épidémies intra hospitalière dans
les hôpitaux sud la timone de grippe
pour les gens qui étaient rentrés pour
je me rappelle en a eu 18 cas là un
service d'orthopédie tous les
malheureuses personnes âgées qui étaient
là ont été affectés parce qu'on a fait
rentrer une grippe la danse à corps donc
ce problème là il existait avant cette
pandémie existe toujours c'est à dire
l'hospitalisation d'un des services
spécialisés pour les maladies
infectieuses des gens contagieux est une
chose qu'il faut repenser et qu'il faut
réorganiser sans avoir des hôpitaux
lazare et comme on avait avant et donc
ça a été évalué par nous comme par
d'autres en nouvelle zélande en
australie que pour quelque chose qui à
ce niveau de contagiosité il faut 20 à
40 lits par million d'habitants donc on
sait combien on sait ce que sont
maintenant les chiffons les art d'accord
une gestion donc un prêt cheminement d
urgence une gestion pendant les périodes
contagion importante de services qui
sont spécialisés là dedans et alors là
vous pouvez gérer la vaccination parce
que le personnel qui appartient à
l'assistance publique qui décide d'aller
dans ce service là a comme engagement
personnel de se vacciner pour les
maladies qui sont là dedans et donc s'il
veut pas vous l'affecté un autre service
d'accord vous leur envoyez pas il n'y a
pas d'obligation vaccinale pour
l'établissement
mais il ya une obligation vaccinale pour
aller travailler dans les services de
contagieuse qui est défendable
c'est raisonnable et on a montré qu'elle
est beaucoup moins de transmission à
l'intérieur de ces réseaux contagieux et
le troisième point qui est très qu'un
point très intéressant c'est qu'un des
modes de contamination majeur c'est un
service de radiologie
il faudra penser à la gestion de sa
contagiosité nosocomiales des
désaffections de la grippe dans le monde
entier un fumer chez nous on a constaté
la même chose ces services de radio ser
que vous emmener quelqu'un qui va passer
la radio du poumon
alors qu'on sait que c'est inutile
l'argument s'en fiche c'est ce qui
compte le mix et le l'état la disney ou
la prise donc être avare de déplacement
dans l'hôpital avare de déplacement à la
radiologie pour éviter qu'ils aient
contact d'autres malades et contracte ou
un fake le manipulateur radio qui minent
m va affecter les autres malades
voyez ces des clés qu'on a appris dans
cet épisode de pandémie qui fait que si
on applique simplement les leçons que
nous avons eues dans sept pilotes de
pandémie nous devrions y compris la
saison prochaine ce que je pense qu'au
final en cas de réduction je sais pas
mais je prie je pense qu'on aura une
autre épidémie de grippe saisonnière et
prochaine
c'est vraisemblable et bien si si nous
sommes préparés nous diminuerons de
manière très importante y compris la
mortalité intra hospitalière à la
contamination nosocomiale et nous gérons
d'une manière raisonnable cet exemple ce
qu'est ce que ce que ce que je veux dire
la vaccination
la vaccination des personnels c'est une
chose la deuxième chose je crois alors
vraiment c'est une erreur je l'écris
c'est assez tôt la vaccination il faut
faire ça avec les médecins généralistes
et donc ça depuis le départ de dire
c'est le préfet qui va gérer les
vaccinations
c'est une erreur c'est encore une fois
c'est parti de la vaccination encore une
fois lavés bavière en disant écoutez on
fait un truc c'est la guerre on va
mettre les gens dans des stades à tous
les passionnés c'est un truc la
vaccination de masse c'est à mon sens il
fallait mettre ça à disposition des
médecins le fait de pas le faire ça a
fait que les gens qui sont en réalité
les troupes pour lutter contre les
maladies quand même c'est les médecins
se les rendre au style ensuite le même
diffuser un discours qui était fâché et
vexée contre les mesures
gouvernementales qui les sortent et d'un
circuit qui est leur métier c'est
déraisonnable donc et soul et je pense
que toute l'organisation depuis le
départ avec cette stratégie sur les
barrières de la gestion de sa commune
guerre ça à marginaliser tout où les
toutes les compétences et que c'est une
erreur dont on peut être que d'accord
enfin nous toujours là-dessus
complètement juste encore une petite
question mais je crois qu ensuite il ya
mes collègues elle vous poser une
question des questions l'une des leçons
qu'on peut tirer aussi c'est finalement
le la totale préparation absence de
préparation plutôt du corps médical et
des corps paramédical à la lutte contre
un danger
je prends quelques les angles qu'on a on
a eu à ge de poussière qui passions et
territoire national on n'a pas les
professionnels de santé qui sont
préparés à s'organiser entre eux pour
lutter contre ça on a d'autres en paca
cadarache qui explosent ou marcoule qui
explose on a un nuage atomique
on n'a pas de plan de lutte contre les
les accidents de ce type là avec en
particulier la participation des
libéraux fin des médecins le corps
médical
à l'intérieur de cette lutte est ce que
vous pensez qu'il faille que nous
allions jusque là dans notre rapport
dire que peut-être quelques pins faudra
mettre en place comme dans le cadre des
collectivités locales nous les coller
les mairies les villes on est obligé de
mettre dedans en place des plans de
lutte contre les inondations des plantes
duel contre c'est contre cela et on veut
on a tout un protocole qui est mis en
place et qui s'applique et qui marche
bien et si court principal se seraient
nécessaires position toujours dans mon
rapport je continue à y souscrire qui
était dans ce pays a des problèmes que
dont je maintiens qu'il est critique
c'est le l'organisation d'une façon qui
ne soit pas purement volatile pour faire
face simplement un problème ponctuel tel
qu'il est posé par la société je vais
donc à l'époque et je maintiens que
c'est une réforme structurelle qu'il
faudrait faire même si elles luttent
contre un certain nombre de corporatives
qu'est ce qui se passait quand il y
avait la crise du bioterrorisme
on a créé une commission dite au
terrorisme distincte de la commission du
clain distingue de la commission des
antibiotiques est là pour la ville on a
créé une commission de la lèpre et tous
ces gens sont les mêmes d'accord donc si
on arrêtait tout ça et qu'on disait
écouter on va faire un comité de lutte
contre les infections en général dans
chacune des structures de soins qui
regroupera alors vous ayez pourquoi on
pouvait pas le faire c'est parce qu'on
peut être parce qu'on ne peut pas le
faire parce que les clins peuvent être
dirigé par les anciens de santé publique
parce que si vous mettiez dans la
commission des antibiotiques avait des
pharmaciens presse que si vous disiez
qu'à la france les médecins qui est géré
ça d'un coup il ya tous les pharmaciens
qui monte au créneau
et puis tous les gens de santé publique
qui monte au créneau parce que ça
devenait maladie infectieuse donc c'est
des questions purement et simplement de
lobbying de qui ont empêché de regrouper
parce que vous auriez moi moi je disais
c'est pour ça que je prends souvent
l'exemple des pompiers apprend que j'en
veux spécifiquement aux pompiers mais la
seule manière vous le savez dans un
hôpital sert chef de service de
chirurgie ça arrive dans mon hôpital
peut interdire aux clubs passés chez lui
rendez compte donc on est en train de
parler obligés de me croire mais même si
vous croyez les chiffres du ministère
mystère dia karpine moi j à douze mille
morts de dans les hôpitaux de maladies
nosocomiales ministère nyala 4000 des
morts par un seigneur 0 mais comment les
pompiers on était le pouvoir et
responsables du club n'ont aucun pouvoir
quelle est leur pouvoir le pouvoir c'est
de recommander donc vous pouvez pas
fermer un bloc
vous ne pouvez pas vous parler de
distribution d'alcool nous on connaît un
chirurgien qui est contre l'alcool
vous pouvez pas fermer son service vous
pouvez pas lui imposer c'est à dire que
il ya une espèce de déraison là dans le
fait d'en dans le dans le fait que si
vous avez la colossale donc une espèce
de déraison là et donc que qu'à un
moment 6 6 7 6 7
cette grippe est l'occasion de réfléchir
sur les pôles de compétences ce dont
nous parlons ces deux pôles de
compétences et donc il faut organiser
vous voyez moi je vois se succéder
toutes ces choses je dirais je vais plus
d'ailleurs au ministère j'ai fait une
fois c'est beaucoup si vous voulez sur
poteaux pouvoir la vitesse d'application
des recommandations qu'on va faire ce
qui aurait probablement permis à jean
françois va t il rester quelques mois de
plus la mise en place de ça c'est
terriblement long donc c'est pas dans le
temps qui m'intéresse mais encore une
fois si j'ai vu passer donc la mise en
place déclin et puis kouchner a mis en
place en place le médecin prescripteur
d'antibiotiques aussi une loi jamais
appliqué jamais eu les postes de péage
et puis ensuite moi mon époque ça a été
les trucs sur le bioterrorisme
là aussi distincts et puis on choisit il
serait trucs bio terriblement forme de
région militaire plutôt qu'en forme de
chu je me rappelle qu'il a fallu que je
me batte au ministère la santé tout le
monde était hostile au fait que
contestent les poudres et que donc on
commence à créer de l'architecturé dans
les endroits dans lequel on est là 24
heures sur 24 a fonctionné tout le temps
c'est à dire dans les chu il voulait
mettre ça à l'inra l'institut pasteur
vous téléphonez le vendredi à 6h il ya
plus personne sur la chu pour quelqu'un
qui répond pour pour s'occuper des
choses dont pierre les centres de
compétences on peut pas les inventer
c'est les gros chu et dans ces centres
de compétences et ensuite dans tout les
services d'hospitalisation est obligé
d'avoir un clin est obligé d'avoir donc
il faut regrouper les forces dans les
centres de compétences qui ensuite se
mettent en réseau avec les grands
entre de compétences pour que les
réactions ne soit pas piloté par des
gens qui sont ici complètement distant
du terrain mais par des gens qui sont
sur le terrain et qu'ils sont ensemble
donc si vous voulez il faut réunir les
compétences ensemble et il faut pas
décliner 36 truc c'est pas normal qu'ils
aient une commission d antibiotiques
qu'un qu'ils soient distincts c'est la
même chose
lutte contre les infections nosocomiales
et là le truc il faut qu'il y ait une
structure décision et qu'ils aient
autorités une autorité comparable à
celle des pompiers qui disent écoutez un
homme est un danger public on vous ferme
tant que vous vous l'avez pas les mains
ou tant que vous n'avez pas un
comportement qui est cohérent avec les
choses qui sont reconnus comme étant
nécessaire pour lutter contre les
infections à terminer je passe donc la
parole à mes collègues qui se fait
qu'apprendre madame de questions par
rapport à ce que voulait dire ça veut
dire que concrètement est-ce que vous
supprimiez aujourd'hui si vous étiez par
exemple conseiller au cabinet du
ministre le comité contre la grippe
oui bien sûr d'accord et deuxièmement si
vous étiez aussi conseiller du ministre
l'année prochaine à la rentrée va se
poser le problème à nouveau de qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire avec la vaccination
pour celles et ceux qui se sont fait
vacciner une première fois
est-ce qu'il faudra les revacciner
quelle est la politique
vous serez kosiner vous préconisez y
seriez vous en la matière donc je vous
dise que ce que je que je pensais
l'époque est ce que je pense toujours
c'est à dire que je suis ce que j'avais
écrit en préliminaires dans mon rapport
au ministre c'est que les crises ne sont
pas indépendantes les unes des autres et
que les hommes ne sont pas différents
donc il faut créer compétences
il faut créer de la compétence réuni
regroupés sur des sites qu'ils soient
des sites réels et et pas des ministères
je continue à penser ça donc ça c'est la
réponse aux premiers mois la deuxième
réponse je voulais c'est que là aussi il
faut être très pragmatique c'est à dire
que il faut et donc je veux que nous
avions eu l'occasion d'en parler parce
que je crois que au sénat repas sera là
le problème de la loi de bioéthique
il faut pouvoir très rapidement testé
sur les échantillons que nous avons en
stock
quelle est la persistance des anticorps
sait le faire et techniques pour le
faire et donc on peut très bien dire
maintenant écouter on prend un
échantillon de pas 150 200 à 300
personnes vaccinées et regardez qu'est
la rémanence des anticorps mois d'août
où sera comme ça on sait le mesurer et
on a su grâce à ses techniques de ces
rôles ou cessons ces techniques de
sérologie vous savez sûrement si vous
avez entendu parler d'homme dollars qui
ont permis de montrer la proportion que
ya seulement 30 % des cas grecs qui
avaient été symptomatique
grâce aux techniques de sérologie l'on
s'est rendu compte que parle parle
l'inhibition mêmes accusations sur le
technique sérologie assez robuste est
assez ancien donc on peut très très bien
mesurer le degré de protection
on peut le faire donc la politique si
vous voulez il faut pas là la question
c'est pas une question de la vie je
voulais il faut mesurer non mais une
mesure pratique ce de dire écoutez voilà
le ministère finance
une étude auprès de 300 personnes
vaccinées pour savoir quelle est la
rémanence en moyenne des anticorps chez
gens qui ont été vaccinés et en fonction
de cette réponse là vous dire eh ben
voilà il faut vacciner for vaccines il
faut par l'accident exact quand on dit
que là comment dirais-je d'un point
c'est sûr on fait en france sont fatales
yards 4 la protection biologique n'est
pas toujours identiques à la protection
clinique presque l'airé il peut y avoir
une position logique sans protection
clinique d'embats oui ou non vous savez
bien que c'est pas des réponses et des
médecins c'est pas les réponses a oui ou
non ces réponses généralement il ya une
très très bonne corrélation entre la
protection biologique elle aurait après
les exceptions sont multiples mais mais
ces études là les questions que posent
ces études là son étude scientifique etc
existent moi j'avais dit dès je crois
vous êtes l'exégèse de feu mais de mes
communications la presse pour j'avais
dit parce que c'était publié en juillet
dès juillet qu'on savait qu'il y avait
besoin que d'une régulation et que les
anticorps de manière suisse quand je
l'avais dire je vais écouter c'est pas
la peine je l'écris je les dis je dis
attendez c'est pas la peine de faire un
truc on a les études avant les études on
pense tout ce qu'on veut mais quand on a
les étudiants mais les études mais alors
il croit pas on est tous ses études
c'est tout ça sert à rien et mon opinion
vaut mieux que toutes les études
scientifiques
il y avait des études qui mesurait ça à
l'impact de ça donc on le savait il ya
deux études sont publiées en même temps
dans new england sur la réactivité h à
la salle est née juillet savait qu'une
seule injection était née sa vie a été
très ému nos gènes et que c'était pas la
peine le français
oui moi je
si ça oui c'est pas la peine de faire
mais parce qu'il fallut attendre et qu'
il ya une autre fantasy qui a été fait
en france et donc je pour lequel je vous
assure que c'est une chose je m'excuse
je suis aussi deuxième chose à laquelle
je suis particulièrement en six ans
c'est là qu'on voit là la création
permanente de au comité de saisie et
j'espère qu'il ait pas proposé la
création d'un comité de la grippe parce
que des reds ne vous inquiétez pas là
dessus vous pouvez je suis bien d'accord
donc dans les eaux comité elles sont
pleines pour nous envoyer les références
des étuis 2 oui oui bien sûr mais si
vous envoyez un petit mot en me
demandant sa queue leu leu leu leu leu
là l'autre chose c'est que si vous
voulez il a il rentrait dans la
vaccination en plus une confusion
extrême qui est un truc qu'on a inventé
en france dont on sait pas pourquoi
parce que quand vous avez au comité qui
se réunit en plus au mois d'août
vous savez plus qui décide de quoi et
donc d'où est-ce qu'il est sorti en
france qu'il fallait pas faire en même
temps la vaccination h1n1 la vaccination
saisonnière ce cas rentrait confusion
extrême
oui je sais mais c'est passé sur rien
scientifiquement tel seul pays à
proposer un truc pas et personne n'a
jamais pensé à ce truc là
ces sorties de l'imagination d'un des
types qui étaient autour de la table on
a dit on fait comme ça où on fait comme
ça il n'y avait pas de sciences il n'y
avait pas de base est rien mais tout
cela je m'excuse c'est comme ça qu'on a
pris décision enfin évidemment moi je
voudrais bien savoir d'ailleurs on a
bien vu moi je dis ça dès le début aussi
j'ai dit attendez mais moi d'ailleurs
pour moi j'ai fait deux racks et en même
temps publiquement pour que les gens
disent attend elle va pas perdre de
temps compass a pas de sens ça n'avait
pas de sens et d'ailleurs on est revenue
dessus quelques mois après en disant on
a finalement ça n'a pas de sens mais
donc ça veut dire qu'il y ait des prises
de décision là et je reconnais que je
plains la ministre parce que dans cette
situation là elle avait le haut comité
qui lui avait dit une chose et donc à
une excitation des foules contre le
vaccin qui faisait que s'ils allaient
proposer autre chose ce serait fait
lyncher et ensuite l'europe disait
attendait oms n'a pas encore pris la
décision puisque décision au niveau
européen c'est encore plus haut niveau
français n'a pas encore pris la décision
pour savoir si finalement il faut faire
deux injections vous faire une injection
alors qu'on avait les travaux publiés
donc si vous voulez globalement il faut
faire attention que tout c'est au comité
ensuite ils donnent leur avis et puis et
politique est bien embêté s'il tient pas
compte de leur avis il prend des
responsabilités bien plus grave que s'il
tient compte de leur avis en dise
finalement c'est de leur faute donc il
faut faire attention à pas multiplier
c'est au comité dans lequel c'est plutôt
des gens qui sont hors course qui sont
là parce que moi je vous assure j'ai pas
le temps d'aller dans les eaux comité
qui on est dans les eaux que notre
combat est intéressant c'est très
intéressant dont elle c'est très
intéressant parce qu'effectivement le
cerveau féminin a une capacité
d'adaptabilité alors beaucoup plus
constitué par rapport à ce que vous avez
dit sur l'adaptabilité tout à l'heure je
pense qu'il ya plus de réactifs à bombay
ça fait longtemps que je pense que les
agiles berba pied on a les chiffres pour
ça je ça fait longtemps que je pense que
les hommes sont toujours moins
performant on se traduit maintenant
l'allèle triomphe au 21e siècle on vit
dix ans de moins on va mois l'université
et on va plus en prison il ya dix fois
plus d'hommes en prison de femmes les
hommes vivent dix fois moins dix 10 ans
de moins et qui à 60 % de femmes par
rapport à 40% d'hommes donc je pense que
c'est nous qui sommes dans une situation
actuellement d'infériorité évidente
sociale bien tout est là dans meurs plus
jeunes marchent bien
lemagit juste une question c'est que
vous avez tiré les leçons de cette
pandémie donc cette épidémie qu' il ya
quand même une chose qui était quand
même inquiétante que les perroquets
sellal les cas assez particulier de
décès notamment où j'ai visité service
de pédiatrie mari ou dans le cas
d'épidémie de grippe saisonnière on n'a
pas tous ces problèmes de
détresse respiratoire qui ont touché de
très jeunes enfants
puis on a aussi ces décès de personnes
jeanne qui sont décédés et ça je crois
que il ya eu un facteur peut-être
psychologique à focaliser sur ces décès
dus à la grippe je pense
et quelle leçon aux en tirer pour la
saison qui vient
alors encore une fois je te puisque
c'est le point sur lequel m'interroger
mois eu des morts de documenter ce qui
est très différent des morts prévu ou
calculés sur des différences
statistiques de documenter vrai dans le
monde pense que je peux bien 15000
mortalité qui n'est pas négligeable qui
est avéré qu'ils sont des gens qui
n'étaient pas des gens comme on a dit
pour la canicule qui allait mourir dans
l'année qui vient les gens jeunes qui en
sont morts qu en fait due forme
gravissime
donc c'est une maladie qui a été grave
qui a tué des gens alors c'est toujours
très compliqué parce qu'encore une fois
quand on prévoit qu'il y avoir dix mille
morts et que y'en a que huit cent ont
dit c'est pas assez
mais en tout cas c'est incontestable
donc cette mortalité surmortalité et
cette gravité
nous on l'a constaté au fait qu'on a eu
un besoin je pense que je suis passé été
quantifié en france mais en tout cas
nous aurons la quantifier
on a eu un besoin d'ouverture de lits de
réanimation et de création de
circulation extracorporelle pour pour
oxygéner ces patients qui étaient tout à
fait unique qu'on n'avait pas jusque là
donc il ya eu des formes très grave avec
une augmentation du besoin hospitalier
de prise en charge en réanimation
respiratoire très significatif
ça c est incontestable donc encore une
fois je reviens pas sur le fait
je vous conseillerais on ne peut pas
parler de 2000 grippe est une chose qui
était banale libye c'est un vrai je
crois que c'est pas vrai à côté de ça
encore une fois les leçons qu'on en tire
d'abord je crois que ce qu'est ce qui
est acquis déjà dans le cadre de delà
des connaissances et de compétences dans
les insuffisances respiratoires c'est
une chose très importante
est-ce que je crois j'ai a vraiment des
leçons enfin je vous ai donné quelques
unes nous c'est ce qu'on écrit on est en
train de faire un article sur l'analyse
de ce qui s'est passé à marseille dans
la pandémie c'est les points qui nous
semblent importants c'est le pré
acheminement le traitement différencié
des urgences le diagnostic de proximité
où on a fait un point of care
directement dans les urgences on a
commencé à remettre ça à partir de juin
2009 à partir de juin 2009 on rendait le
résultat en moins de trois heures sur
place par parra 9 k way on a été les
premiers au monde
il ya eu la guerre et les antiquaires on
a mis on a mis ça au milieu des urgences
de l'hôpital nord qui était celui qui
recevait le plus de ce que la kia le
service des maladies infectieuses et
donc on rendait tous les résultats
non seulement celui des savonnettes qui
avait été positif que dans 50 % des cas
qu'on pouvait rendre tout de suite mais
pour les autres en biologie moléculaire
après on a été débordé à partir de
septembre on n'arrive plus à le traiter
comme ça mais tant qu'on traiter 20 30
prélèvements par jour dont les traités
directement et donc les gens pouvaient
tout de suite les données tamiflu ou
conseillé le masque à partir de ça donc
le diagnostic direct immédiat
sa mise en place très rapide est un
élément essentiel aussi la france avait
fait une autre option dérivés de du
bioterrorisme qui était de prendre les
mêmes laboratoires qui étaient ceux du
bioterrorisme pour que on y fasse
seulement là les diagnostics c'est pas
raisonnable de diagnostic moléculaire
c'est un truc qui doit se faire dans
tout hôpital et comprennent hôpital
général c'est quelque chose extrêmement
banal il ya des automates pour faire ça
et donc il a aussi la leçon pour la
prochaine épidémie c'est qu'il faut il
faut évoluer il faut que dans tout
hôpital d'une certaine taille et la
capacité à faire le diagnostic
moléculaire surclasse un mois je trouve
ça ridicule rendez compte qu'on recevait
les prélèvements qui allait de perpignan
avignon jusqu'à nice pour nous envoyer
le prélèvement à marseille fra
diagnostic et ti pure les allées le
temps de transport le truc qui se
perdent et c est en même temps nous
alors on avait dans les yeux alors que
mon laboratoire est alors un état la
timone on avait délocalisé dans une
pièce qui fait
12 mètres carrés un interne qui faisait
le diagnostic moléculaire
donc ça saoule et la technique
moléculaire qui s'adaptera toutes les
épidémies
c'est quelque chose en diagnostic de
proximité c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel qui doit être diffusée dans
tout le pays parce que c'est simple
c'est pas compliqué donc c'est pas des
grosses machines c'est de la technologie
simple automatisé c'est fiable il faut
des contrôles mais c'est fiable donc il
ya une diffusion des technologies
actuelles qui doit évoluer qu'il ya un
élément important le traitement
différencié d'urgence est un point
important de localiser dans tout dans
tout hospital hôpital d'une certaine
taille
un certain nombre de lits en chambres
seul capable d'être utilisé par des gens
spécialisés dans la prise en charge la
contagion ça servira tout le monde ça
servira pour la grippe ça servira pour
les diarrhées ça servira pour les
bactéries multirésistantes ça servira
pour tout le monde ça c'est le troisième
point les quatrième point effectivement
c'est d'avoir un non non non c'est pas
vrai et en plus de ça nous alors je peux
vous dire on a fait vraiment dire on a
fait un truc qu'on a fait une différence
il ya une différence significative dans
le degré de contagiosité à l'intérieur
des services dans les services médecine
interne à ces maladies infectieuses
c'est pas le même métier mais même si
vous dites c'est dans un service de
médecine interne il ya une partie qui
réservé aux maladies infectieuses si
vous voulez vous développerez de la
compétence mais c'est des gens qui vous
savez c'est compliqué il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ne croient même pas à la
contagion notre rapport à la contagion
s'est compliquée la cour de la contagion
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on voit c'est
très compliqué et donc c'est un métier
la lutte contre la contagion c'est un
métier c'est pas la médecine interne
c'est autre chose c'est plus simple à la
fois la gestion quand on gère c'est
moins complexes et moins compliqué et en
même temps ça nécessite une
ritualisation des fonctionnements que
n'aime pas les internistes interniste
déteste les choses qui sont répétitives
car est simple
avec eux c'est simple c'est pas
compliqué la contagion c'est de la
rigueur médecine interne c'est
l'imagination c'est pas pareil c'est pas
et même bien avant de vous libérer
monsieur professeurs je vais vous poser
une dernière question concernant la
vaccination alors m'ont effectivement
vous avez répondu mais j'aurais voulu
avoir votre avis concernant la commande
des 94 millions de doses
est-ce qu'il vous semble que cette
commande compte tenu des informations
qu'on a à l'époque je vous rapelle que
au moins de mai 1 le 5 mai ne serait
qu'un d'état américain avait avait
déclaré un publiquement que le virus
h1n1 n'était pas plus virulent que celui
d'une grippe saisonnière
est-ce que vous pensez que l'achat de 90
millions de doses alors évidemment
compte tenu du fait qu'on savait pas si
il suffisait d'une ou deux injections
disons que 45 milles 1 l'acompte de 45
millions de traitements est ce que ça
vous semble prend portionné haut risque
ou disproportionnés par rapport aux
risques tels que on le pouvait le
percevoir le connaître à l'époque alors
dû aujourd'hui avec le recul il est
facile de dire c'est délirant mais est
ce que seront replaçant dans dans le
contexte est ce que ça vous semble
une commande déraisonnable surtout
qu'elle intervenait avant que toute
stratégie vaccinale est été élaboré si
vous voulez j'ai trouvé quand j'ai vu la
première partie si vous voulez de du
plan grippe qui était basée entièrement
sur les masques et de tamiflu j'étais
extrêmement extrêmement inquiet parce
que je savais qu'on ne peut pas
contrôler une pandémie avec les masques
et le
le tamiflu si elle s'est vraiment
développée on savait qu'il ya des
résistances assez facile au tamiflu
on n'avait jamais évalué masquer la
seule chose qu'ils avaient vraiment été
évaluées avec succès c'est le lavage des
mains savez ça pour commencer on savait
que ça limitait la contagion savais pas
ce que donnait masquant les très peu de
rythme j'ai donc je change pas au moment
où c'est arrivé j'ai trouvé que c'était
une bonne nouvelle que le gouvernement
prenne commandes massives de vaccins
après 90 millions de doses ça m'a paru à
l'époque un peu beaucoup mais je
trouvais que de réagir contre une le
début d'une pandémie grippale en dix ans
la meilleure manière de lutter contre
une maladie contagieuse
c'est le vaccin c'est raisonnable c'est
ce qui s'est passé dans le passé c'est
raisonnable
donc moi j'ai pris ça comme une bonne
nouvelle si vous voulez jeu on était
dans un plan qui était sur lequel je
trouvais que ça n'avait ça n'avait pas
vraiment à voir avec ce que je
connaissais de la stratégie de lutte
contre les maladies infectieuses c'est à
dire j'ai un peu l'impression que je
voulais que tout ça était une espèce de
gigantesque dessin animé où il y avait
un truc qui arrive et on arrêtait en
mettant qu'on appuie en mai les masses
moi j'ai prescrit je prescris des masses
depuis dix ans ça fait mal parce que les
gens les ans la ville ont fumé discuter
porter un masque
quand vous dites on met un masque et
vous rentrez à la maison mais personne
d'important il faut bien que les gens
mangent il faut bien qu'ils touchent et
donc est d'ailleurs si vous observez
réellement voyez bien que les choses se
passent beaucoup plus par les mains que
par les éternuements
donc je voulais l'idée qu'avec un master
à mon sens c'était plus sonné comme une
réponse de jeux vidéo on appuie on a un
masque et on arrête le truc mais c'est
pas vrai les humains c'est compliqué et
c'est pour ça que je vous dis il y avait
une différence formel entre nous ont
testé le masque depuis une dizaine
d'années mais c'est infernal
il a fallu inventer soul et on a appris
ça vous donne des choses de docteur si
vous voulez sur le terrain on n'a pas de
chez on demande aux gens s'ils fument
maintenant les patchs parce que si vous
voulez patcher pas vous pouvez les
mettre dans des chambres au sol avec des
matches fait ce que voulait il se tire
toute la journée pour les fumeurs m'a
volé retrouvé en bas il pousse le masque
et y fume tout ça c'est des trucs
pratiques
le masque chez les fumeurs ça marche pas
d'accord donc c'est un écho et atx est
tombé sous l'oeil a donc toute une mise
en place de choses si vous voulez qu'ils
sont de la pratique où on voit les
échecs au fur à me
sur ça qu'il faut qu'on ait des gens
terrain qu'est ce qui fait que on
n'arrive pas encore une fois les choses
sont pas virtuels
voilà c'est médecine c'est compliqué
après vous voyez dans la vaccination ce
qui m'a choqué c'est plus l'organisation
que la décision la décision vous dites
j'ai vu trop large avait pas où vous
avez vu trop là en tout cas la
vaccination pour lutter contre la grippe
c'est incontestable on prend ça après la
gestion de sa se dit maintenant on va on
va organiser ça dans les stades vous
voulez parler préfet ça c'est à mon sens
c'est une erreur mais de vacciner miles
at il quand il m'a dit quand a lieu non
pas engueulé gens parce qu'ils décident
vacciner quand même année ont quant à
eux c'est normal c'est raisonnable oui
blake c arrive trop tard comme c'est le
cas on s'aperçoit que bien peu de deux
français ont pu effectivement profiter
oui encore une fois je pense que s'il y
avait eu un ajustement si vous voulez au
fur et à mesure sur ce qu'ils étaient
les cibles réelles sur ce qu'était que
on s'est retrouvés avec des stocks de
vaccins qu'ils aient compris au début de
nos débuts son accent alors que la
maladie continue à augmenter
qu'on n'a pas réussi à utiliser un donc
on a eu un vrai problème qui était alors
il ya une chose qui était imprévue c'est
que l'épidémie s'est déroulée de manière
à symptomatique beaucoup plus rapidement
que ce qu'on croyait beaucoup de gens
symptomatique et donc la population
était beaucoup plus rapidement et me
disais que ce qu'on pensait ce qui
explique très certainement qu'elle s'est
arrêté beaucoup plus tôt et puis et puis
donc je je je crois que c'était moi je
crois que c'était une bonne décision
je pense que c'était la seule décision
raisonnable c'était de dire écoutez ça
pas sur les bras oui mais voilà comblé
le dos pas à 700 millions très si vous
voulez encore une fois placé que moi
pour voir ce que souligne âge de l'état
sous les gaspillages dans les crises et
c'est inhérent aux crises de faire les
gaspillages je croise un jour je
discutais avec un très bon économiste
des crises qui explique sa crise il ya
toujours un gaspillage dans les crises
parce qu'il ya une sur réactivité qui
est liée aux crises parce que
elles peuvent toujours être plus sévère
que ce que l on les a comprend les
observe pour que ça me choque pas quel
gaspillage encore une fois c'est plus la
décision en soit ce qu'il fallait
prendre décision de vacciner moi je
prends ça comme tous les gens qui
luttent contre les maladies contagieuses
crois ça c'est quand même la meilleure
manière d'arrêter les choses
deuxièmement en revanche je suis j'ai
été dès le départ mais je me suis
exprimé vous le savez j'étais réservés
moi j'écrivais ça je crois le prêt de
l'ordre des médecins en juin il faut
tout de suite mettre les médecins
généralistes dans le circuit pour
l'accès nation s'ils voulaient que ça
marche donc disais